more literate and more literate It’s obvious that
the industry is gaining momentum many times
more, they started to know that not everything is
enough yet, but they are running out of money, they don’t have their
own base when they don’t have their own
base, no ideology, no actual
industry, no money, no
own nothing, actually then there is no
future.  we
have
[music] there
was only one stove and I took the scythe; there’s
nothing else you can get out of there.
I just don’t know what to do. I just need to put up supports to
make a roof and completely
lay down the wall to do
this. These are the kind of
comrades we have who helped us
tonight, nothing
[music  ]
dreamed